music fills the streets of Latin America
day in and day out
they're always bustling with people it's
the tapestry of life here
it's hard to believe that they're
totally under the control of crime gangs
though but be under no doubt they are
our guide all in speaks to them
continuously on the phone driving with
the door open so that they can see us
they gave us a permission to enter
without that agreement this would be
lethal
we watched continuously we just don't
know by who people scratch out a living
to survive here many resort to crime but
the crimes are committed within these
communities there is no escape we're in
the northern triangle of Central America
it's three countries making up
Guatemala El Salvador and here in
Honduras the countries are well known
for their incredibly violent crime gangs
and they're also well known for the
killing of women
femicide it's absolutely endemic we've
come out here to find out why
virtually every home we parse we're told
has a story of remarkable violence gang
murders are common what starting though
is the sheer number of women being
killed for being a woman
it's called femicide and it's out of
control
[Music]
we were taken to a house of corrugated
sheets and wood heading to meet the
surviving victims of this femicide
epidemic they're pretty much on their
own yet Rosalinda and Isaac's mother was
murdered by their stepfather their uncle
took them in and he was murdered
relatives helped them as much as they
can but this little boy is the one who
protects his sister and brother well
they have is this photograph of their
mother it keeps them going what effect
living through your mother's murder has
on such little ones is difficult to
gauge but yet has a burning desire for
revenge their mother's picture is always
with me a pocket mirror photos magazine
no I will hand it over to my mother you
playin vemula Karissa okay okay yeah
give me a micrometer
[Music]
a femicide problem combined with the
random murder of the woman's children
it's partly to do with the crime gangs
and poverty but it's also part of a
culture that categorizes women as
basically disposable items rich or poor
it makes no difference
women are not even second-class citizens
Lily Anne was beaten to a pulp by her
partner the police wanted money to help
and they wanted her sister for sex now
she says she is tough and a survivor no
more tears I asked her to tell us what
it's like being a woman in Honduras
Sarah Lewis a who no recuerdo meaning
yes Bango they want a hint and we mill
the dunes whoever don't they meet my my
vo your lens here yeah I'm starving mark
I yeah forgive me mama VI Valencia
entonces como que yo Cayenne his siglo
la mujer en la lucha yo se en este pais
coeur MO Coeur MO real go pero cuando no
meat mo en esta lucha estamos de puesta
de roto
do what make sure
[Music]
the sheer number of killings on a daily
basis here is quite extraordinary
we know for certain of at least three
murders every night least aid those are
just the ones we can guarantee happened
[Music]
navigating through the gang lands is
crazy dangerous not least because the
boundaries aren't even a street apart
this is ms-13 Church
this is now very Oh a teen territory
and now this is the territory of the
avocado gang silly name but the avocados
killed eleven last week one continuous
theme running through this is the
disproportionate number of women being
killed amongst the four killed here was
a 17 year old girl and a member of the
barrio a teen gang the gangs use women
as part of their extortion racket
because they are less likely to be
stopped by the police the girls join the
gangs because they can provide them with
some protection this woman was in charge
of extortion her gang has allowed her to
retire to look after her mother we can't
identify her
even speaking to us carries a death
sentence she spoke because she wants
people to know what is happening here
what happened to the people if you do if
they don't pay the extortion we give
them a time frame to pay then a warning
and if they don't pay then the members
will kill them do you think you'll ever
join the gang again no if you did try to
join and try to leave what would happen
they would kill me poverty and crime are
a lethal mix for women in the northern
triangle but the culture of society here
and even the law are awfully helpful
either dressed in yellow prison shirts
we could just make out one of the female
labor workers on a penitentiary farm in
El Salvador their sentences are long
often 30 years they grow vegetables and
watch by armed guards sell them outside
the prison their crime they have a
miscarriage
in El Salvador that can put you inside
for life in an anonymous private house
owned by a charity they meet as part of
a self-help they campaign for their
friends in prison to be released they've
served their sentences but the stigma of
their so-called crime means that getting
back into society is hondo so trace
recuperar amo de Libertad recupera Mona
liberty' del los burros Salim o de la
cárcel
pero estando estando
a LOF wherea no encontramos con otro con
otra barreras no encontramos con con
nuevas discrimination yo creo que ma
payor todavia porque ahora hasta yeah
esta se ya la gente que que que no
Houska cuando lleguemos
poverty crime society and even the law
then combined to make Central America
one of the most dangerous places on
earth to be a woman even the dead are
denied any dignity scared of gang
retribution even their families don't
report them missing a man fighting for
justice for the dead in El Salvador is
Israel teeka's he is a body hunter with
a constant army and police guard he
scours the hills around the capital San
Salvador looking for murder victims so
far he has recovered over 750 killed by
the crime gangs that terrorized the
so-called northern triangle of Central
America in recent years 70% of them are
women this is the killing field of the
ms-13 gang 31 people have been executed
here he is found 21 their murders were
all brutal
one body host opponent yeah and a woman
how was she killed
she had a car I could could he could he
had it could be the farm all or body or
body or body i it could so the whole
body was cut today yes yes yes and when
she came here she was alive she died
Jessa life is life in here killer
yeah but the the witness said that a
hour and 15 person fifty asses in here
and only one victim only woman the gangs
want t Cass dead he knows this they've
tried but he is a driven man I mean even
me missing my son or might whether IIIi
I kill I either no not is easy loss our
family
Central America the northern triangles
one of the most dangerous places on
earth to be a woman
[Music]
these religiously conservative societies
offer them little protection and seems
utterly resistant to change these young
girls already pregnant can wish for
anything for their babies it's that
their fathers protect them or that they
have a boy who at least has a chance
you